well we begin this NewsHour with
breaking news three Israeli soldiers and
one Egyptian officer had been killed
during exchange of gunfire near the
Israeli border with Egypt Israel said
the standoff lasted for several hours in
the Negev Desert an area known for drug
smuggling activity well let's go live to
West Jerusalem and speak to Villa Marx
Willem what more do we know about this
operation I know we're getting
information right now
yeah that's right we're just getting a
statement from the Israeli military
actually in the last few minutes talking
about the fact that there was a male and
a female Soldier on their border post
right on that border with Egypt in the
early hours of this morning they were
killed several hours later when more
military forces were sent down to the
area they started to conduct searches
they identified what the Israeli
military calls the assailant in Egyptian
policemen they say and in a further
exchange of fire another Israeli soldier
was killed another Israeli soldier also
injured and the assailant the Egyptian
policemen as they describe him was also
killed this is of course been a pretty
significant incident in this part of the
world for the first time in quite some
time it is really significant to say
that the Egyptians and the Israelis are
now cooperating of course they have that
border there it's been relatively secure
for the last decade or so but they are
cooperating their investigation villain
this sounds like a huge huge security
breach when we're talking about a border
Zone can you describe the area where all
of this took place
this is remote this is mostly desert
area with a lot of screen not huge
amounts of tree cover some shallow
valleys and hillsides the Israelis
started to build more than a decade ago
now and more than 400 kilometer fence
essentially Walling off from the Red Sea
almost as far as the Mediterranean that
was intended to try and stop some of the
Armed incursions they'd seen in previous
years going back to 2011 or so as well
as some of the migrants traveling from
parts of Africa into Israeli territory
that wall has for the most part held
pretty firm there hasn't been a huge
number of these kinds of incursions in
recent years but this therefore is a
very unusual incident
Villa marks there across that story for
us with all the latest from West
Jerusalem thank you very much fellain